The gloriously colourful and glitter-filled
world of Trolls gets a whole lot bigger in
Trolls World Tour when Poppy and Branch discover
there are six Troll tribes, including the
fearsome Rock Trolls led by hard-rocker Queen
Barb!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing over 50 amazing hidden
details, easter eggs, and secrets packed into
the brand new Trolls sequel.
And keep watching to learn how you can win
one of these incredible official movie merch
packs.
When Queen Barb and her Hard Rock crew gate-crash
the Techno Trolls' underwater rave, they arrive
in some scary-looking critters called Angler
Buses.
The design of the Angler Bus is based on the
real-life anglerfish, an ambush predator often
found in the murky depths of the sea, up to
a mile below the surface.
Using that particular fish as inspiration
for the Rock Trolls' transport was a great
choice by the filmmakers,
because anglerfish are usually dark and have
loads of sharp teeth in their enormous mouths
which can expand to swallow prey up to twice
as big as their bodies;
and all of that perfectly fits the Hard Rock
Trolls' terrifying vibe as well as their punk-rock
style with all its dark leather, denim, and
metal spikes and studs.
During Barb's "Crazy Train" song, we see the
angler buses burst out of the ocean and drive
around madly on land while she rocks out.
World Tour director Walt Dohrn has said this
scene was inspired by the huge chase sequence
from Mad Max: Fury Road which included crazy
drummers and rock guitarists playing on some
insane and gargantuan vehicles while speeding
across the land.
Just like the first film, the animation in
Trolls World Tour is astounding and there's
such an incredibly tactile, textured quality
to both movies that you feel you could almost
reach out and touch it in all its felty, fuzziness.
And right from the start, there's loads of
lovely little visual details.
The underwater empire of the Techno Trolls
mixes the digital world of techno with the
home-made textiles we see in many of the other
troll lands.
Which means we not only get lasers, LEDs,
and trolls with fibre-optic hair, glow-paint
patterned skin, and 8-bit beating hearts,
but we also get landscapes made of crochet
and macramé, that's the art of making things
using knots.
And the way the neon-coloured crowd moves,
at first draws on the natural world, mimicking
the motion of a wave in the sea, which is
a nice touch given they live underwater;
but as the song's about to reach its peak,
things look more digital and the way they
move takes on the look of a spectrum analyser
on a home stereo.
When it comes to the film's title, if you
look closely at the fiery flames beneath it,
you'll see that they look like bright orange
strands of Troll hair!
As for the waterfall in the Pop Troll kingdom,
that's made of long, narrow strips of shiny
tinsel!
And the lonesome, dusty world of the Country
Trolls is filled with buildings shaped like
patchwork-quilted cacti, roads made of burlap,
and when you see the farmland from above,
it looks like an enormous multi-coloured patchwork
quilt.
The filmmakers wanted to make the big chase
scene where Hickory and the Pop Trolls are
run out of town feel like how kids play with
their Troll toys at home on their bedspreads,
so they decided to make the cliff they fall
down out of a stack of quilts and folded blankets.
And did you notice how crucial vinyl records
are in the design of the Funk Trolls' home?
Not only is the room where they keep their
tribe's musical string full of columns made
out of records, but the outside of their spaceship
is mostly made out of silver records.
Also, instead of the scrapbooks that tell
the Pop Trolls' pop-washed version of Troll
history, when Prince D tells Poppy the real
history of the six tribes, visually the story's
told using the cover art of a double album.
The little gem that the Classical Trolls have
on their tummies is a lovely tribute to the
1990s toys called Treasure Trolls that had
a little jewel in their belly button which
you could make a wish on.
And in fact, there was already a reference
to those particular troll toys in the Trolls
Holiday Special.
♪ Good Luck Troll Day
Put a gem on your stomach ♪
♪ Then you spread a little charm
Let a friend belly rub it ♪
♪ Rub it, rub it, rub it
Rub it, rub it, rub it ♪
The leader of the Classical Trolls is called
Trollzart, which is a play on the name of
the famous classical music composer Mozart,
who like his World Tour counterpart was also
often pictured wearing a white wig.
Keeping with the classical theme of Symphonyville,
if you listen very closely, you can hear the
tribe's critters all bleating the word 'Baaach',
which is a pun on the name of the renowned
classical music composer, Bach, mixed with
the usual baa sound made by sheep or goats.
"Baaah..."
"Baaach."
Oh, and if you look closely at the animals'
design too, you'll see that their legs even
look like little musical notes!
World Tour also has many call-backs and similarities
to the first Trolls movie.
"Oh, I can stop the feeling."
Barb and the Hard Rock Trolls invade the Techno
Troll kingdom just as they're in the middle
of a huge rave party, similar to the first
movie and how the Bergen Chef found the trolls
in the forest when Poppy threw a big party.
And when Cooper poops out a three-tier cake
with candles after he's terrified by some
weird and wonderful creatures,
"Happy Birthday?"
it's a call-back to how he was so scared that
he pooped out cupcakes when Chef invaded the
Troll kingdom in the first film.
"Erm...
Cupcake?"
And if you keep watching through the movie's
credits, you'll see those strange creatures
gobble up Cooper's cake!
Also in the credits is a Caterbus similar
to the one from Trolls Holiday.
And like so much of the "strange fairytale-like
dream" quality of the Trolls franchise, the
various weird critters the Trolls use for
transport owe a great deal to the odd creatures
and dream-like worlds created by renowned
Japanese writer-director Hayao Miyazaki, who
co-founded Studio Ghibli and gave us such
classic animated movies as My Neighbour Totorro,
which featured the iconic Cat-bus.
OK spoilers ahead for the ending of the movie
now.
You can skip to the time on screen to avoid
them if you prefer.
Another call-back in World Tour is when the
six strings are destroyed and all the trolls
lose their colour,
similar to how the trolls faded to grey in
the original movie when they were trapped
and thought they were all about to be eaten
by the Bergens.
In the sequel, the trolls' colour begins to
return when Cooper notices his own heartbeat
and that the music is still inside him.
We see his heart glow and slowly, bit by bit,
each of the other trolls' hearts also lights
up as they sing and their colour returns to
them.
The fact that music is in the Trolls' hearts
and not the strings was hinted at several
times earlier with many heart patterns and
symbols appearing throughout the movie,
from the thumping heart beat in the opening
scene,
to heart symbols on the chests of the Techno
Trolls,
the heart-shaped bubbles they blow,
and the explosion of digital hearts when King
Trollex drops the beat;
to the Pop Trolls' heart formation during
their opening medley.
Then there's the heart shape the Classical
Trolls and the Country Trolls form when playing;
the heart-shaped glasses that Poppy, Branch
and Biggie wear when they perform in Lonesome
Flats;
Chaz's heart-shaped chest-hair and the heart
pattern he blows with the petals from his
saxophone;
"I can't feel my face."
and when the Funk Trolls sing "It's All Love",
some of the spinning records light up and
pulse in a heart-shaped pattern.
If you enjoyed watching the Bergens in the
first movie and the Holiday short, then you'll
be glad that, even though they don't have
a starring role this time, they at least get
a little cameo in the new film.
After Poppy and Branch fly off together during
the movie's credits, Queen Bridget and King
Gristle pop up in a quick mid-credits scene
where we find out that they're disappointed
to have missed out on all the fun.
"Aw, Grissy, I guess we're late to the party."
"Aw, balls!"
"Grissy."
"But who's gonna eat my cheese balls, babe?"
As well as the many other Troll tribes, we
get to meet some brand new Pop Trolls including
Legsly, who has extendable legs meaning she
can go from short to tall very quickly.
Unlike the other trolls though she can't extend
and manipulate her hair, and there's a nod
to this when the Pop Trolls use their hair
as legs to dance about during their opening
song.
Oh, and by the way, Legsly, which definitely
feels like a limb-based pun on the name Lesley,
is voiced by the aca-awesome singer-songwriter
Ester Dean.
"Thanks, Poppy.
Kisses and donuts and sprinkles!"
Who's not only written masses of hits for
the likes of Rihanna and Katy Perry, but she
also played Barden Bella Cynthia-Rose in the
Pitch Perfect movies alongside Poppy voice
actress Anna Kendrick.
Another new Pop Troll is Skyscraper who, like
Legsly, is also the opposite of many of the
other Pop Trolls because he's a fuzzling-style
troll who has an enormous body of hair all
the way down to his feet.
But unlike fellow fuzzlings such as Fuzzbert
who have no head or face, Skyscraper has four
heads all of which speak in unison.
"Or Skyscraper Troll?"
"Yeah, different like me?"
And Skyscraper was voiced by the podcasting
McElroy Brothers who campaigned to appear
in World Tour after they discovered YouTubers
had voiced characters in the first movie.
Each brother also voiced additional characters,
with Justin playing the parts of Beat Drop
Button
"Let's do this, King Trollex!"
And Tumbleweed;
"You suck!"
And Griffin voicing Country Music Tear while
Travis did Rocker Tear.
When the Snack Pack goes undercover to infiltrate
the Rock Trolls, they each wear outfits and
designs referencing icons from Rock 'n' Roll.
"We need to go undercover."
"But how?"
"With fashion!"
Biggie and Dinkles each take on a different
look from Elvis Presley.
Legsly has a black-and-white striped outfit
that references Elvis's Jailhouse Rock.
And Satin and Chenille's clothes and red and
white pompoms are nods to the cheerleaders
in the musical movie Grease.
"One, two, three, four!"
♪ Rainbows, unicorns
♪ Everything nice, yeah
♪ Sugarplums, fairy dust
♪ Brush your teeth.
Now, what did you enjoy most about Trolls
World Tour and who are your favourite new
characters?
Leave your thoughts and comments below!
And before you go, I've got several packs
of official Trolls World Tour merchandise
to give away!
Make sure you subscribe and follow the link
in the video description or the pinned comment
for a chance to win!
You can also tap left to watch my full Trolls
playlist including amazing deleted scenes
or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!